austin texas the middle class famous
store is coming to town we're going to
be at the moon tower comedy festival
this week april 22nd we're doing our
stand-up show and playing ayg with the
crowd and we're doing a live podcast you
can either get badges or you can get
tickies come see us let's party we're
also going to be in denver phoenix salt
lake city pittsburgh buffalo detroit
chicago chicago rose mine second show at
it in chicago only late show tickets
left in chicago get those tickets now
it's a party we'll see you there welcome
to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r u garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out if they grow up to be classy
yeah or if they're just a big old piece
of trash trash drive i'm your host truly
coming at you on a gorgeous day down
here at aunt tony's basement she almost
got caught stealing at the wawa again
what yeah there's a half a turkey hoagie
upstairs if you want it cause i can't
have them my co-host is coming at you
from across the table check out the
patreon it's a family episode right here
circling the wagons hanging out me kippy
and my coal store are still hanging on
for dear life thing won't quit i think
got aggravated since the last time i've
seen it
he got to a bar fight this weekend but
he's not getting any wake up on the
wrong side of the bed or something
knocking a full eight
i thought i was going to cruise through
on this one but [ __ ] blew up on me
now it's scabbing the whole nine yards
it's tough man what are you gonna do the
kid gets laid i don't know what to tell
you give it up for kj everybody okay
that was a quick transition talking
about your herpes introducing your best
friends seamlessly folks he's got a head
like a football give it up for talking
about my herpe and i like kev by the way
okay what's up kev no you can't do that
no kev no you you i'm just saying
i can't do that what do you mean i can't
doesn't you've never done it in 10 years
oh i wouldn't call you kev that's your
new nickname kev
i don't call you kj in our personal life
either
you're kev okay no
i'm taking kj back
then yep kg is back all right toby
you're kj from now on hey gang thanks
for tuning in as always please make sure
you rate me if you subscribe on itunes
full video available as you know those
numbers are
cooking
cooking over there
then i have to contractually say check
out the greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com
are you garbage you can sign up you get
bonus episodes at ayg every week
if you're on a 10 level which is
above and beyond
the most popular level buy like six
times
bananas we're this close to be able to
buy our way at anything you get on the
heart please keep it going you get the
hard feelings over there which is like a
nitty gritty hr session we really
you know really take the gloves off and
let it fly we're not fans of each other
no
not on that show we're not
or in real life
uh and then we'll do live streams with
our top tier uh so much fun check it out
uh it's a good time support the pod love
yous come do a live show also come see
us yeah [ __ ] out when does this come
out tomorrow night we're gonna be in
austin if you're listening to this look
at that the night it comes out we're
gonna be in austin friday night
tejas moon tower comedy festival doing
our show some stand-ups so maybe with
the crowd it's going to be a good time
yeah it's a good time quick stop at
bucky's too walk around see what's going
on you're on a tight diet tight tight
diet check out the patreon for more i
can't wait to hear how that's going i'll
be laying down some ground rules
on the next uh hard feelings just so you
know okay taking the control back
putting in my power i'll be having my
meals alone that's what i'm saying okay
fine
hoping you would fight a little harder
on that but fair enough how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good one of my best pals of the
whole wide world and i love him i don't
care how long his hair is give it up for
t-bone mcscruffins toby
mcmullen what's up dudes hey pal yo so
to avoid any airbnb
kerfuffles down in tejas i have decided
to find my own lodging i will be staying
in a buckies
not bad because they got everything down
everything i gotta get yourself a smoker
a grill some deer pellets i'm gonna set
a tent up in the jerky aisle dude i
don't hate it
we should camp out why don't we camp out
what camp out of his friends that way
there's no attempt to get locked out of
a tent at 3am
that's what i need thought you were a
bear dude
you bear spray me
it's me a [ __ ] i thought it was
a bald bear i don't know kitty what are
you doing sneaking up on me like that
holy cow family episode what's cooking
with you
poorly time sip there uh
i saw you were gonna throw it to me real
quick and i was already i had already
made the decision to take a little nip
got hands of gold over there okay i got
some gmo in here take off the edge do
your little nippy whippy hey i'm driving
out of here when's the last time you
drank in the morning
uh saturday night really yeah we went
golfing oh that doesn't count
i will tell the cop to pull me over
i gotta you gotta talk to a judge in
dennisville township
i shoot 18 over now it is a prick
sir i mean you step out of the is that a
three wood you're good
just show joshua t
your honor
i was sure it was mini golf but still
couldn't get in that damn clown's mouth
why are your balls purple
what does it go
like golf balls at mini golf they're not
white they're like different colors do
you remember the golf balls you would go
some places and they would float in the
water
no you don't remember that there was
like water where like remember because
most many golf places
had the brick where it wouldn't go in
the water like it would
there was some oh oh okay i got you i
got it there was some that didn't have a
barrier to the water yeah to make it
harder you're screwed but it would it
was like running water or whatever like
down a hill like a fountain type thing
uh-huh and it would float and you would
have to like pick it back up and play
from the beginning oh yeah that sounds
like alien technology that's crazy yeah
sure okay
that's what blows your mind i've never
seen a golf ball that floats why don't
they all float what are we doing
what why don't they all float because
it's changed the weight the size
everything can't use it on the tour why
not what if everybody uses it okay well
you switch to tennis balls or something
all right so the gators don't get you
what
there's alligators on golf courses so
how would that how would that stop if
the [ __ ] ball floats so you wouldn't
have to go swimming there to get it
you're swimming in to get the ball
anyway i've seen the guys go in and get
it oh yeah yeah they're looking for a
win
i don't think it didn't touch the ground
it's too loud
saying [ __ ] tin cup okay
great movie by the way it's on like
links with a
rake i got a louisville throwing it up
um
what can i do for you where were we um
i did something pretty
trashy this weekend that i was like a
little bit ashamed of
um
uh more street clothes at the golf
course no but
i ran over a caddy i was gonna say this
is hard feelings but i had to buy
a whole golf outfit at dick's the night
before because you're a pork chop what
do you what's that mean you tried your
stuff on it didn't fit no i didn't have
any i thought i just we we got real
jammed up when we left the studio the
other day
i had to say traffic he got a baseball
uniform on
that's all they had
like an old-school stirrup like my
butt's all big
no no you're in full catcher skier dude
trying to i'm throwing it down the
fairway
did you buy it he's out did you buy a
nice pair of golf pants and a nice golf
shirt yeah well i stopped just to buy
would you go eagles what'd you get did
you get the did you get the real puffy
pants like an old-timey direction i had
a jerk off but they are a little flared
at the bottom they all have a little
bg's vibe too
i was walking around looking like a
[ __ ] jerkle hey give it up for night
fever huh
moonwalking
i moonwalked to the first t-box ladies
hal the greens today
what the [ __ ]
i've never noticed that bell-bottom golf
they're not
around like a sailor in the 70s they
they just had a little they were
everything was like kind of snow panty a
little bit if you catch them they were
wide legs what's happening what's
happening cool cats and hip
daddies he definitely didn't tape her in
put the jive turkey down for a par-4 huh
my man
i was going to save this for hard
feelings but collar that wide he can't
miss i got the big
i got the shirt collar outside my jacket
collar
going for bogey
what'd you do confess your sins my son
wait are we still in dicks or what
we're outside of studio 54. i'm doing
keyboards my jaw's all over the place
i'm talking larry ludes over here 130
135
where's that cart girl
comes the heat man quit hassling me oh
god that's funny no so i was down the
shore and like i had stated i got an
airbnb for me my wife and my newborn son
ah my fourth young hanzi young hansi
um
for the new pooch uh just because my
[ __ ] mom's house is packed
she's not the biggest fan of dogs hmm
so
um i'm slowly breaking her in on that
but i didn't want to be like well the
dog's staying here for four days type
thing you know what i mean i'm with you
i understand so
and also it's nice to have a little
private time you know privacy a little
privacy
so
uh
my wife takes uh
the dog to the beach so he comes back
all saying he's in the water and stuff
like that like in the tide whatever you
know he threw his dog [ __ ] in the water
what threw his dog [ __ ] in the water is
he loving the beach he was having a
great time so dog came back a mess we
washed
the dog in the airbnb we gave the dog a
bath in the airbnb
which is like i didn't feel good about
cause that's like a that's a lot
to do
the whole place smells like wet dog he's
shaking
or using their [ __ ] towels to [ __ ]
clean it
it definitely changed the vibe of the
place for sure dude
i don't know the last time you smelled
like a soaked [ __ ]
dog
but they were using like the vo5 to
shampoo them and stuff whatever was in
there
you got per plus
[Laughter]
it was just like i'm just saying i used
to airbnb my place out and if
i came home and someone had washed their
dog in my tub i would be quite upset did
they say anything you get kicked out oh
we left this morning we didn't get
kicked out i was smoking bernies all
over the place
inside outside like a gentleman that's
jersey it's [ __ ] north wildlife dude
lucky i wasn't on the roof with my shirt
off
surprise you didn't didn't say you had
to smoke bernie's
minimum of two packs inside for the
weekend yeah
that's pretty trashy man it's real that
was that was real i didn't feel good
about that
i just the place there's dog hair all
over they i don't have like cleaning
supplies were you allowed to have a dog
i'm glad i have a dog emotional support
animal ah i acted blind the whole
weekend
touching the landlord's face
coming in through the windows yeah
what's going on
um
how the like nieces nephews must love
they love the dog everybody loves the
dog although we did take him over so
it's like now i'm the guy he's a puppy
so you can't leave him alone that much
but now i'm the guy taking him to like
the [ __ ] family party and stuff
because i'm like hey we gotta fight but
my answer everybody's like [ __ ] bring
them just tied them up that's pretty
trashy i know but showing up with the
doll but it is it's either that or i
don't i can't [ __ ] go you know what i
mean we have a couple that does that
well we're not gonna do that but they
also all my cousins when it's a puppy
it's okay but when you got a [ __ ]
you're showing up like an eight-year-old
beagle no like rockstar
foggy i'm talking
uh our one family member rolls in with a
about a 37 year old dog
i'm not lying yes dude this thing is
falling apart yeah i don't get that if
it was a car you'd be totaled yeah i
don't i don't get that at all and it's
like
the dog's just like wandering around it
has that he smells like hospice like
that old dude i know it old dog smell
you know what i mean you got a [ __ ]
bacon wrapped scallop in your mouth
you're ready to [ __ ] throw up i was
with my my my wife's friend one time uh
in new york and we were going out to
like oh whoever's in town let's go out
to a nice brunt like a nice
brunch down in like the west village or
something
she brought this bulldog that smelled
like a bum's nut sack dude you could
smell this thing from four tables away
people were audibly gasping somebody
eating truffles what's going on
people were audibly gasping at the smell
of this thing and she's like do you take
dogs and the girl's like is it emotional
to support animals she's like i got and
they were like
like trying to eat an eggs benny [ __ ]
throwing up in my mouth yeah dude it's
bad listen don't be that guy
rolling into the four seasons with snots
bunch of eye boogies on the dog he's got
that black [ __ ] under his eye i love my
dog hit the powder room will ya
love my dog more than anything in the
world but yeah when it starts to get to
that point you got to keep men we did
that with our old dog yingling he got to
a certain point where it was like he can
no longer go out in public he was like
phil spector you just couldn't bring him
out he's in france
[Laughter]
no but you can't because dude his breath
literally smelled like [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
you gotta you gotta take care of it
that's why we got to clean them at an
airbnb
um as a puppy that's okay i know yeah of
course but we did take them and then my
my cousins all have dogs
down the shore
uh like big [ __ ] uh shout out the big
man shout out to myers has two big
[ __ ] golden retrievers does he i
didn't know that he's a retriever uh lab
sorry yellow labs uh and they beat the
[ __ ] out of hanzi it was pretty good to
see in a good way
yeah they were just like [ __ ]
manhandling them um
but i was a guy like out back all night
like all right i'll be out back it was
just like it was tough i don't like
being that guy no
but you got to do it for a short period
of time you know what i mean
yeah get him in school he'll be all
right he's a good kid trying i imagine
hanzi fights dirty he's throwing
throwing sand and gold retriever's eyes
and [ __ ] he only ate a lot of sand and
then throw up in the car on the right
owner
[ __ ] i'm like we were just driving home
this morning like do you smell dog food
i'm like
turn around there's just like is it half
a north wildwoods beach and
a cup of kibble in the back seat crab
running around back there yeah there's a
couple of sand crazies in there
those things those tiny no those tiny
little clams look a little clams yeah i
like the little sand crabs when you
stick your hands in and they come up and
that you play anything those things look
prehistoric
everywhere just in jersey i don't know
they're not in hawaii i know no i know
people eat them they call them yeah no
you can't eat those there's no meat in
there i'm telling you i know people that
eat sand crabs mud bugs yeah mud bugs
they're my parents
your parents are mud bugs but you know
what i don't [ __ ] with at all what even
since i was a little kid i knew to stay
as far away from them as i possibly
could and when they were dead they stunk
the high heaven i'm talking about the
horseshoe crab oh yeah i showed my wife
one of those for the first time she was
like what the [ __ ] dude i'm waiting for
that thing to jump up and [ __ ] stick
to my face you ever see a horseshoe crab
t-bone no oh
it's literally jurassic park
it's like a it's like a world war ii
helmet with a tail
yeah
it's like
i'm not [ __ ] around it's like a
german helmet running around oh these
[ __ ] things are the worst dude get
out of here with them things i've never
seen one alive i've never seen one in
the water
you don't want to see one of those guys
creeping up in your bed they come in
twos one's behind you dude i've only
ever seen them dead on the beach yeah
and then one day when i was a little kid
my cousin picked one up and held it and
i saw the underside of it like where
like the legs and [ __ ] are i didn't
sleep for like two weeks i thought that
thing was coming to get me yeah there's
no bueno they're shifty's those [ __ ]
things no i don't think they have mud
bugs in hawaii classy operation over
there they got mantis they got
hammerheads tiger sharks
centipedes
[Laughter]
okay
um
all right let's uh let's get into a
couple of do some cues guys as you know
it's a patreon episode so when you or so
sorry it's a family episode so when you
sign up for patreon we will answer your
garbage question on the air that's the
best way to do it we get hit up we get
the emails we get the dms
but patreon gets first crack at it i'm
sorry that's just you know that's the
cool guy club money talks
[Applause]
hey i appreciate the follows but those
patreons are all right
they're homies
[Laughter]
um
all right this one's kind of bonkers
this is from thomas uh is it garbage to
go to a 7-eleven
pay for a big gulp
makes sense you're like oh this is i see
where he's going with this i love a big
gulp
well we gotta change that
bad court two fat court season two um
there will not be a season three
i figured we'd do the movie after that
some said he couldn't get fatter i'll do
it el camino uh is it garbage if you go
to a 7-eleven pay for a big gulp and
fill it up with coffee creamer so that
you can keep it in your fridge at home
instead of buying a full price container
at the grocery store
what's the numbers on that prop what's
gotta be about the same no big gulp's
got to be what big old 64 ounces
right
right b and what's a big goal 219
probably okay you're not getting 64
ounces of cream for [ __ ] two bucks
184 large big gulper okay type in pine
cream is probably three four bucks a
bite of cream
do half and half
no you're not putting heavy cream in
your cream i don't know
cream isn't it how much is half and half
the internet isn't instantaneous
no it is
it proper is hold on a second say that
again half and half
half and half say it one more time half
and half okay i don't know weird said it
weird the first time you're like half
and half
[Laughter]
get a weirdo
are you a half and a half guys no i'm
nothing uh half and half is a mixture
it's milk and cream everybody knows i
know calm down i'm trying to look for a
[ __ ] price you bows
3.89
yeah okay but we go so you're getting
479
two bar whatever yeah it's called three
bucks but that's for like 409 for a 16
ounce coffee mate yeah 409. coffee mate
that's not real cream okay 639 organic
valley jesus christ that organic
valley's a ripoff too so is horizon the
red 79.
horizon is but regardless you're missing
a bigger point this guy's getting four
or five of
for two more them the price of one this
podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy sure is gang you gotta
remember the most important relationship
you have who with who yourself what you
gotta take care of yourself i know i
found that all out the hard way yeah
whether it's going to the gym getting a
haircut take care of yourself and let me
tell you something if you're having some
issues get on better help they can help
yes it's easy uh better help is online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to if you're
into that kind of thing you can do a
little peeky peek
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy you can be matched with the
therapist in under 48 hours which is the
big thing if you're trying to get into
therapy it's very hard to find somebody
new you call they pull you hey come here
and a half weeks and you get there the
guy or girl is a bozo you want to switch
it up i know this way 48 hours you're
just in the pool then you can tighten it
up figure out a new guy give it a try
and see why over 2 million people have
used better help online therapy this
podcast is sponsored by betterhelp and
all you garbage listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
garbage that's better help
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash garbage do it yeah okay
let's talk about all forms all form all
form all form all form now listen we all
know about helix
the greatest mattress company to ever
live
guess what what's that they're getting
out of the bedroom where are they going
they're doing in the living room
tell you that reaping is fresh
little role play over there on the alt
form i know dang they're getting into
the sofa game and they're absolutely
fantastic we got one sitting in here
right here kippy brought it in built the
whole thing put the thing together most
comfortable couch i ever sat on yes i've
ever passed out in the sugar combat it's
the easiest way you can customize the
sofa by using premium materials at a
fraction of the cost of traditional
storage you pick your fabric if you want
spill stain spill resistant stain
resistant scratch resistant plus they
can absorb a fart pretty good
just our little secret uh you pick the
sofa color color leg size the whole
thing whatever you want you can do uh
arm chair all the way up to an eight
seat sectional it's the best way to
customize and look cool while doing it
yeah like you said it took me like i
think the whole thing took me 25 minutes
to piece together bing bang boom easy
peasy uh if getting the sofa without
trying it in stores sounds a little
risky i get it you don't need to worry
though you get 100 days to decide if you
want to keep it that's more than three
months if you don't love it they'll pick
it up for you and give you a full refund
there you go all four wants to do their
part uh and all for exclusive discounts
for teachers students military and first
responders look at that out there boots
on the ground taking care of it all form
also offers finance and flexible
payments so an amazing sofa is never far
away and they offer a forever warranty
there's louis forever to find the
perfect sofa check out all form.com
garbage and all form is offering twenty
percent off all orders for our listeners
at allforeign.com garbage one more time
all form dot com slash garbage twenty
percent off do it yeah yeah that's
pretty good i've never heard it it's
really trash i thought it was gonna be
like in you you fill up whatever and
then i never thought about stealing the
creamer that's next level dirtbag i've
noticed patty is is is pilfered
pillaging uh our local she's got sticky
finger what'd she take the little
creamers no that's big oh dude stealing
a little cream or something if you've
got little creamers in your house like
you're a diner get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah little salt packets no she takes
straws
cups
napkins the lid patty what are you doing
he makes good money stop stealing from
the local grocer i walked there was a
huge thing of straws i'm like what the
[ __ ] did you get these she's like wow
the cashier wasn't looking
that's crazy caught somebody slipping uh
yeah
but i do get that i mean that's
that's a lot of coffee though are you
going right i guess you're going right
back to the house yeah throw a lid on it
they don't [ __ ] know man put a straw
in it act like you're drinking it
refreshing
[Applause]
i mean
it makes sense
yeah i mean sure yeah it makes sense
dirtbag move very very imagine if my
whole thing every time you go and pour
yourself a cup of coffee you're reminded
what a piece of imagine if you have
company over and you got to take a
[ __ ] big gulp and be like how much do
you like you know hey there's no cream
in there
look at the mountain dew bottle it's in
there
yeah that ain't that's not a good thing
how do i afford a place this nice
i steal my gas
i save 88 dollars a month on half and
half yeah forget about acorn just like
i'm stealing f
uh i've said it once i said it before
half and half of your cereal is really
something else buddy stop even saying
that kind of stuff in the old days
that's all
i know but the more you say the closer
it is the reality all right
if you if you if you kill them off
they'll never happen again i have some
on the card too uh this one's from lee
ever fall off a ladder trying to dunk a
basketball
i mean then you're not really dunking a
basketball if you're on a ladder depends
on how you have the camera who gives a
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
smoking mirrors
i remember when those adjustable
basketballs nets came out
we thought we were [ __ ] well there
was two there was two levels to them
there was one where you had to get the
broom and shift it or there was the
crank my my buddy had the crank dude it
was a gold rilla you just went like this
and it would lower it down oh my god
talk about a couple of slam dunk
contests in there dude we had the
[ __ ] stick am i going to know it was
like the taller kid could do it yeah my
dad did not put this was not up to code
as they say the one side came down was
what in the ground or was it like one of
those ones with the sand in it it was in
about
a pillbox worth of concrete is that the
one that you still have a pole in your
driveway with no net on the the pole was
supposed to be i think i'm going to
mention this the pole was supposed to be
removed last summer which i understood
that as they were going to come and dig
it up
but it's just the pole is just cut
sliced yeah at the top right right at
the top
dude you hit your tire with that it's
over
dude i'll [ __ ] pull like a plane in
there or something you can't
you can't just [ __ ] hard steel right
there it was like a lightsaber went
through it
slice you up plus that's prime time wasp
messed in there well i'm saying if you
if you put some soil in the hole
oh what make a what put a flower in
there yeah
no what's that hippie [ __ ] what are you
talking about now we want
raw pole yeah i want to pop my tire
like a real man makes backing out of the
driveway a little more interesting
especially in the snow
they've got those they got the hook
spikes like an embassy
do you ever get caught on them no my
family friend did we we were at a soccer
tournament i think for my brother and
his son
and i had him at the soccer field and we
had parked somewhere i forget where it
was and he [ __ ] went out the wrong
way and he had like a jag or a beamer he
had a little bit of cash nice shout out
to doug he listens dougie um
and uh
he drove the wrong i think he just got
twisted around or whatever wasn't paying
attention and i didn't know i that him
doing that when i was six still scares
me today dude i had to we had to return
the ones
at the airport the rental car i was like
you guys
this is the right way right yeah i don't
[ __ ] trust them those things look
like they would slice you open
is that necessary by the way the five
dollars for parking how are they allowed
to do that
to completely arrive at property ruin
your car you're stealing spike strips
what's going on here throw a flashbang
card gets declined hit you with some
rubber bullets
yeah dude that shit's [ __ ] up yeah all
right it's two hour parking and if
you're late we will hit you with the oil
strip
we are gonna key your car if you're not
back by five the car is ours what
jesus christ i hate those things patty
ran over a uh guy
gypsy curse the whole family
don't say that um oh hold on i was just
talking we were talking about
what something superstitious no i
remember you guys were like oh my dad
hit a deer one time my
cousin hit or whatever my mom hit the
pretzel guy yeah
i told her that i told that story i just
saw her this weekend
i'm like something something you
remember when you hit the pretzel guy
and she goes well he said thank you and
i thought he was like she's still
defending herself 30 years later what's
the statue of limitations kind of
running over the pretzel guy he was
going get the [ __ ] out he was on the
windshield
you have a couple more mustards but she
was still like i paid him and then he
thought like he i think he pump faked
bronzer kooky
my mom ran over the thing in the parking
spot you know the little concrete john
which you might do a grinder on or
whatever it's called
you know the little sandwiches with you
the the little concrete thing yeah
parking block yeah yeah she ran over a
couple of them oh yeah just [ __ ]
[Laughter]
do you ever see the guy that gets up on
the light pole
do you ever see that it was like it was
a video going around recently he's got
like a white big denali or suburban and
he somehow jumps it up you know how they
have like the light pole in like in a
shopping center sure with like the
cylinder concrete like you know that's
like two feet high or whatever well his
bumper gets caught on that so he just
starts like rocking it right and he
falls he finally gets it and he's like
yeah and he puts his thumb up and then
the airplane
[ __ ] dude he is out cold he's like
yeah i just gotta ride
have you ever taken an airbag yeah you
have oh yeah when i i crashed i [ __ ]
wrapped my first lumina around uh the
lumina had airbags
that's not a 32. it's an old shopping
bag
ah yeah have you taken one no oh
i can still smell it i can still see
smell it yeah what's the smell it was
like an explosion the new ones are like
air or something this was like a flash
this was a proper flashbang felt like a
ninja was in the car
they've changed from what they what i
have mine blew up like i had like
[ __ ] soot on my face and stuff it
blows up out of the [ __ ]
out of the steering wheel wait so i
don't understand there was an explosion
it uses either nitrogen or air gone gas
which that does not sound safe now no
what the what were in old ones like in
in 95. this is what they this is what
they they still use the same [ __ ] okay
yeah it uh after deployment a smoke-like
residue will be present in the air yeah
jeez most of this register is talcum
powder that is used to lubricate to help
the air bag you're just getting lebron
james
[ __ ] crash what is that gold bond
what are we doing here
yikes
yeah it's scary i've seen people
uh
you know hours or a couple days after
that's happened to them and their faces
like they have sunburned their face is
like all [ __ ] up yeah dude it's like
someone lighting off [ __ ] bottle
rockets in the car
taking a couple of mortars
i've seen some buddies do that that's a
good time the bottle rocket fireworks in
a car
[Laughter]
those guys aren't still alive
if they are
they're not employed too busy living to
clock in that's right baby
here for a good time not a long time um
this one's from kyle ever move your tv
outside to watch the game
no
we didn't do it i remem i remember my
buddy's neighbor
redid the back deck
the decks and all like where we when we
grew up the deck was just like a wooden
deck and these people
what what no i know now probably 50
grand into this [ __ ] thing had the
archways had the ceiling fans outside
really yeah not my buddy my buddy's
neighbor we would just sit on his shitty
deck smoking cigs like one day you know
what i mean the flat deck is a tough one
that's what i'm saying just a flat deck
with the three stairs up it's not
stained there's block there's bee's nest
everywhere that's so good um was moss
all over that thing
but they had tvs outside that you can do
it classy
you can do tvs outside classes we do a
pretty good i think
we have the uh
the bernie room or the sun room in the
backyard
you open all those up
and then in the
in the summer we take the tv from what
was my room and bring it downstairs and
we we we put it on the wall down there
it's hung
yeah tongue that's uh you hesitated on
yeah it's hard it's hung
what a hanger what's going on it don't
is there a bracket on the wall right now
there's a bracket on the wall right now
going into the house he's not giving me
something you know you're you're you're
hiding something and you know you are
i'm not hiding anything i thought the
fact that we take it from upstairs in
the it winters in my room and summer's
downstairs that's right and then when i
stay there in the [ __ ] summer i got
no tv
like a jerk off surprise you don't sleep
in a burning room have one
right before you go to bed i can't sleep
i get too scared
i get scared of two things i get scared
of those water bugs that have those
little pinchers on them because they
have that wicker
uh furniture down there
that has the little cushions and that's
where those get that's where those
things live they get underneath those
cushions and they crawl up on you while
you're sleeping and bite you plus
somebody coming to get me it's a room
full of glass i can't do that who's
coming to get you i don't know
that's the whole point you're in the
backyard a lot are they stealing you are
they killing you what's in this in this
narrative what's happening i always
imagined it being a little sexual
sexual encounter no i don't know they
kill you they kidnap you my biggest fear
who's kidnapping you
i don't know you're not going easy my
i'm not scared of getting
attacked or anything like that i'm
scared of the i'm i'm afraid of the fear
so my fear
my biggest fear would be
seeing somebody's face in the window or
an alien face is really what would scare
me seeing an alien looking in sure but
i'm saying if the aliens are outside
your house regardless if you're in the
the bernie room or the [ __ ] bedroom
you're pretty hemmed up yeah you're not
getting that way you can at least you're
already out you don't remember it either
what you wouldn't remember it either
it's not gonna let you remember your
[ __ ] neural eyes you yeah you wake up
with a weird little spot keep it moving
get nervous when the syrup spills yikes
what was that movie contact that's a
deep cut that thing scared the [ __ ] fire
in the sky fire in the sky true story
too so they say yeah okay i don't know
a lot of evidence out there yeah i don't
know i don't know either but i remember
i saw that way too young to the point
where it ruined a couple of sleepovers
yeah when he wakes up in that sandwich
bag and they ship and he's [ __ ]
trying to get out
not pod
no thank you
[ __ ] i don't like it um
all right let's see here this is from
mikey whispers
if that's your if that's your real name
that's a [ __ ] home run
shout out to mikey whisperers mickey
whispers he he's got a lymphoma on a
nice little bag he can get you eat your
chicken nuggets with honey i have i have
somewhere used to do that i think in the
90s they used to give you a side of
honey i will tell you exactly where that
was
it was a fine corporation started by the
mcdonald's brothers in san bernardino
california and hijacked by mr ray kroc
and bill
to the greatest restaurant ever
mcdonald's they used to give you honey
when the mcnugget first dropped
first came out yeah
that was the
original sauce was the honey i'm not
talking about that i'm talking about
some casual dining establishment not
fast they all probably bit everybody
rips off mcdonald's okay what are you
their [ __ ] attorney
possibly jesus christ
yeah i'm saying somewhere used to you
would just to sit down and instead talk
about the survivor of an abusive
relationship i know that was insane they
all rip them off all right well how
about for comedy purposes you play along
you shut up toby
the sperch the good name of the
mcdonald's never hurt anybody who are
you whose side do you want croc or the
mcdonald's brothers because if you're
not on the side of croc you should hate
mcdonald's no i'm on the side of croc
so you're a thievin they took a
handshake deal were they nuts
so you're a thief
i think that's been well established
you got my wallet
all right we got an all-time google
search going over here boys what do you
got i typed in who serves nuggets with
honeys when we get to the comments are
going to tell us in two seconds the odd
the autofill is in the morning
you know what i ate the other morning
for breakfast down the shore wait wait
wait let me guess you're never gonna get
chicken cheese steak no chinese food
chinese food cheese steak which wouldn't
be bad no it was more of a snack
uh oreos no
cheez-its
goldfish what is this show turned into
[Laughter]
just let me tell you how about that
pickles
no peanut butter filled purse pretzel
bites with a diet coke nothing
talking about getting your head on
straight man talk about not knowing when
to say stop
those things just they did i even put
them back and then went and got
the top of the fridge i don't know what
it is they were all right it's listen
here's the thing it's not just a
combination
of the pretzel and the peanut butter
there's air in there yes and it's needed
you can like crack them open like a like
like a mussel
and then you have the peanut butter in
there it's something it's just really
how they did it's really good
god all right 100
i agree thanks toby okay but this wants
to move on you guys switch seats real
quick
the the top results for who serves
nuggets with honey is kim kardashian
west
which is not the answer we were looking
for no not at all it makes me like her a
little bit more i say that
cause it's a delicious combo i get it
yeah fantastic um
i don't i guess they still do it
that sweet and sour sauce is too good
though to walk away from
well you got a big guy okay let's talk
about athletic greens ag-1 ag-1 athletic
greens i take it i can tell you why i
started taking it cause i'm a big old
fat piece of [ __ ] i've been struggling
with my weight i've been struggling with
keeping up my workouts and my nutrition
and i'm telling you athletic greens
makes it that much easier i bring it to
the gym with me it powers me through my
workout it's great for your feelings
good great for your immunity all right
you don't want [ __ ] xkb or whatever
this covet like they got thrown around
now you don't want that getting that
yeah take your athletic greens it's the
best multivitamin that you're ever gonna
have yeah tastes great it's fantastic
it's like a super duper multivitamin
it's got 75 high quality vitamins
minerals whole foods source superfoods
probiotics and adaptogens minerals
whatever they or may not whatever they
may or may not be like i've always said
it's lifestyle friendly if you're keto
paleo vegan dairy-free gluten-free they
got you covered contains less than one
gram of sugar no gmos no nasty chemicals
no artificial anything and it still
tastes good
uh all you have to do is uh one scoop
and a cup of water every day that's it
no need for a million different pills
counting out hey did i take the big guy
with this you know no horse
tranquilizers nothing take the ag-1 put
it in there shake it up you know
why am i telling you you know i don't
know why you're telling me uh to make it
easy athletic greens are going to give
you a free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com garbage again that's
athletic greens.com garbage take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
today do it do it all right let's see
here
this is from mark first time long time
are you garbage if you leave airline
tags on your bag so people know you got
airline money
which i kind of do you know walking
around like yeah i was on a plane one
time the originator of that
the ski lift oh the ski lift pass on
your jacket i went skiing once i left
that [ __ ] thing on there until i was
out of college yeah 100 for sure you
keep a couple on there oh
one thing too used to be cool to do was
you kept the same what are they called
trees i think they're called like the
little wire i think they're called trees
okay whatever they're called they
haven't they have like a weird name
that's why it's sticking in my head you
put that on then you fold the thing over
and then the next time you go
because you obviously kept it on mm-hmm
you go over it but not all the way so
like at the top of it you could see like
i was at camelback and then you put it
right under that i was that big boulder
i was at whatever gotcha that was a real
that was like a real everybody i don't
want to show off but i'm also showing
off did you have anybody walking around
we had people walking around high school
with those things on oh yeah it was on
your jacket i mean also
you know you had one jacket you know
true we were multiple g we were in a
multiple jacket household mine was this
it was a cb windbreaker do you remember
cb
is that two you remember op or no
opp ocean ocean pacific yeah you do
remember that was it cool when you were
a kid
really
i had a snowboarding jacket i think it
was a burton or so hmm burton's nice was
all right yeah i used to
denise used to do it all right did she
with this with the gear yeah patty was
terrible
be out there on a lacrosse helmet
[Laughter]
catching snowballs on the lift
stunk um
yeah but that's a big one sure you got
airline money that's good that is good
i've said too i always feel real
confident when i'm walking off a plane i
feel real important
you know what i mean
even though i'm going to stop like the
cinnabon or whatever i'm like all right
gotta get you know out of my way i think
i'm better than everybody even though
everybody's flying they can see me i
still feel like i'm better than
everybody my legs just feel weak when i
go i don't tell him i was in [ __ ] 52b
[Laughter]
i get scared but i always take it off
because i don't want anybody knowing
where i've been or where i was
and plus i make sure also we didn't talk
about the amount of luggage you brought
to california oh my god in the world's
largest pink suitcase you got to look
your best down
one shirt every day
i've done what was in there bowling
balls first of all it weighed all right
hold on let's back this up
no we every time we travel we check gear
can i have this no
get off of that you have two drinks two
drink rules this is empty damn
um no sign
[Laughter]
two drinks can't be just do as i say not
as i do huh hey listen all right you're
right
i'll follow the goddamn rules there you
go now what were you saying i was making
fun of you if i recall
toby can we run it back no so every time
we travel we take just
everybody takes a carry-on bag and then
we have to check uh
at least one bag of gear the tripod some
cameras some merch and stuff like that
sometimes too plus some other things in
there sometimes tube we check two bags
if we're recording podcasts on the road
and we need the we need the whole setup
uh so we're going to california we
needed the whole setup to record pods uh
so we packed two bags two carry-on bags
foley texted me the night before
can i check a bag
i'm like first you own one pair of
underwear and two t-shirts sure you can
check a bag two pair underwear three
t-shirts he then gets there his bag
first of all it is the world it's like
the size of a mini fridge this thing
you come walking out with a pink college
boy with a handle on it
it's huge i had gone and it weighed more
than the tripods the murder it wait it
was overweight it was 53. i had that
jean jacket in there that dude that
thing is heavy
that's like a flak jacket did you jump
into the water with that thing you're
going straight to the bottom stand a
chance no well here's the thing i wanted
to look my i went into california with
the best intentions ladies and gentlemen
please be aware of that and your aunt
suitcase yeah
that's your that's your girls right yeah
yeah i mean that thing's i also lifted a
ted baker bag from her too that i've
never given up little leather [ __ ]
backpack oh yeah thanks that's real that
looks like
what's her name yeah that's like what
she wore in clueless that thing that's
like a real [ __ ]
hoity-toity rich girl in the 90s back i
have that and i have my cpap briefcase
yeah you look real official or as i call
it as i call it the football
walking through the airport in dirty
basketball shorts
i had i i had gone to dxl that weekend
because i wanted to look nice i didn't
want to embarrasses out there no thanks
for not trying to embarrass me which you
did on multiple occurrences
um
what i saw i went i dropped a couple
head dropped a couple of bucks
i dropped
i dropped a couple of bucks on some
clothing what clothing i didn't see any
of this it's not a pink t-shirt that i
wore and one t-shirt there was a couple
other ones why didn't they show up
i don't know every show well i got
flustered when we got thrown out of the
airbnb every people were commenting did
foley take out more than two shirts to
california and i'm like i don't know he
did check 53 pounds of luggage dude i
made the edit of the travel
and there's a whole section in the
beginning it's like us in a car us
outside the airport it's all different
days it's on a spaceship it's all it's
all him in the same ship but it's just
fully in the same shirt so it cut
together seamlessly yeah
man these guys are really working now
that that shirt's working overtime
man you stink with a capital s i brought
out at least nine shirts no you did not
yes i did that's impossible
i didn't i haven't unpacked yet classic
guy
two weeks ago
[Laughter]
i'll take a photograph of my of my
luggage unless the kitty cat's sleeping
in it because she likes to snuggle in
there next to daddy's stuff
anywho cut that
brought two tommy bahama shirts
i bought nine t-shirts
ten pairs of underwear ten pairs of
socks basketball shorts two workout
pants
did they get hell with i said best
intentions
my jean jacket
i brought the steamer why didn't any of
the t-shirts make an appearance they did
i wore multiple different t-shirts
i didn't get anything on that
it was the blue hawaiian one and the
pink one and then i wore something else
to the at um
okay now we know you're lying
insane here's that ladies and gentlemen
in san francisco
you had the blue one i had i had a blue
one and a green one i wore the green one
the first night the blue one the next
then i had the ranch shirt she wearing
reversible t-shirts
the ranch shirt yeah that's not good to
have clothes named after condiments but
it's the shirts
it's the hawaiian shirt that i got ranch
on that night
i'm supposed to know that as the ranch
shirt it's not like when [ __ ] jfk got
assassinated
where were you when foley was wearing a
ring shirt yeah so i had i brought the
steamer for everybody
um
i brought i also i also brought all of
these things and i was i was in a car i
was like my clothes are bigger
you seen those shirts
you asked me to hand you that jacket one
time and like it was one of those things
where you like you it was kind of a bad
movie where you don't realize how heavy
something is like
i can pull my back out my jean jacket
probably weighs 10 pounds
um all right this is from donnie do you
have a relative that lost any fingers or
finger a finger or fingers at work yeah
my grandfather really mushed one of them
and straight flat the rest of his life
too oh that's bad
it was a banker it was weird
what did he do textiles right yeah i got
caught in some machine just smashed it
man that happened a lot of pink fool
back in the day you just crush an elbow
lose an arm from the [ __ ] elbow down
that was that was like wood shop do they
still think they still do wood shop i
don't know
i've had to get rid of that i had wood
and metal shop
i had a kid lose his finger lost his
[ __ ] pointer finger clean off he
called them stubs
not related
his last name was stubble wits
stubby stubowitz
yeah no he lost it and then a kid picked
it up
picked up the thing with his finger with
a pencil and when like had it
well
yeah she's unlocking his iphone and
stuff i think he's ruthless oh i wasn't
that's all you're going to say you put
it on ice try to get in the emergency
room quick no
also do you ever have anybody lose a
tooth and then be like put it in milk
and go to the dentist office real quick
that was a big thing put it in milk yeah
i had a kid curb stomp himself but like
he tripped he was rollerblading and went
down and all right on like the corner of
a curb busted his [ __ ] wide open lost
like three or four of his teeth in the
front and someone was like put him in
milk so somebody threw him in a [ __ ]
a big gulp of creamer and we hit the
[ __ ] brick i'm just gonna say you
gotta talk to our guy
shout out to that doesn't work you can't
put teeth back in no i think you can no
no you just couldn't afford it yeah you
can't put teeth back in your mouth you
can dude no i'm telling you no way
that's crazy t-bone give me some eyes
and ears on that he's a hundred percent
right dude me yes i mean i'm not making
this story up no but i
what i'm saying why would i make where
would that fact go it's a wives tale
some of these old broads they don't know
what the [ __ ] they're talking about
they're all drunk
they don't know what's he's so specific
might be talking about some relatives oh
yeah yeah uh the tooth must stay moist
at all times either in their mouth or it
can be replaced uh or it can be replaced
in the socket gross putting milk
in your mouth or in your mouth next to
your cheek or an emergency but in your
mouth
that'd be wild showing up to the doctor
yeah what can i do for you
start spitting them out they're falling
out like quarters
you got molars in your teeth like it's
kodiak why'd you use chocolate milk just
out of curiosity
my dad my dad's arm is shorter than one
arm shorter than the other growth plate
no i got hit by a car when he was a kid
okay milk truck ran him over believe it
or not hey listen what wait how did yes
we had a
something had to happen he had a crush
run over by a truck okay
and one arm shorter than the other
i but that's not a that's not a medical
diagnosis i get hit by a truck
i wasn't there i don't know when he set
his shoulder could take two inches or
just didn't [ __ ] grow longer yeah
something like that when it's set it
didn't grow right okay
all right i believe it's just sharing
yeah now i know do you think i'm trying
to top your milk story it seems that way
he had to put his arm in milk i swear if
i had to put his arm in ranch dressing
that was a personal preference he could
have done barbecue they said any sauce
really
any cream-based remoulade would do
um
nobody what with fingers or anything
missing but i was petrified in a wood
shop
somebody somebody got sliced
we made like a cigar box we could make
like a box
there's no way they still do that i
would have to assume that wood shop has
been cancelled
i would assume for insurance purposes
they found some old tweets
plus for learning
what are you doing with that they were
just wasting our time no i mean i get it
you know
i mean we did home mac i had to like sew
a bag and make a [ __ ] bundt cake yeah
i guess you're right teach you how to
balance a checkbook or something you
know that's what they should have done
meanwhile i got [ __ ] beakers in my
life yeah i don't give a [ __ ] who franz
ferdinand was all right how do i how do
i get through a grocery store without
embarrassing myself
uh but that stuff uh
that always scared me the band saw
because the [ __ ] was from like the 70s
and the teacher was [ __ ] checked out
he didn't give a [ __ ]
they were on their last legs
but we made uh signs
we made uh we made that we made um
like an especially like an architectural
project where you design a house with
like styrofoam okay i think we did that
maybe yeah the smart kids that could do
that was really cool mine sucked yeah i
was like i'm going for a pueblo or
something it was a real [ __ ] just did
a square square hut terrible speaking of
checked out teachers do you ever drink
with a teacher after you graduated
i think i told the story where i saw
that i would see the guy at cavanaugh's
river deck down in
uh i mean we were underage yeah and he
was hanging out yeah and he'd be like
what's up oh yeah you gotta get out of
here
uh but never
never with like a teacher
no no i assume you have oh yeah it's mad
awkward yeah i don't want to do that i
don't even
i don't like that it's like mixing
[ __ ]
work with pleasure you know what i mean
so i mean fully stop dating
keep it on the books lhr
um all right this one's from pat first
time long time do you or anyone in your
family use the entire stick of butter
like a glue stick to butter toast
instead of spreading it with a knife
that's trash behavior i like this move
though but if it's just you if you lived
alone i feel that's okay you're talking
about you unfold it like a candy bar use
it like a pencil yeah that's pretty good
um i think if you do i think i i've been
to barbecues where they just have one
designated for the corn on the cob you
roll it on there
i guess but i think i saw people like
sticking it like you used a long weight
you know now we have this dish this like
special dish that has little spikes in
it that holds the butter down and you
just roll it over there
man i like a corn on the cob i'll tell
you that a little olive oil and salt and
peppers aren't not bad either okay i
knew some people would put mayonnaise on
there what do you think about that isn't
that like the me isn't that mexican corn
or something like that they put some
other [ __ ] on there whatever that's all
right spice yeah mexican corns cheese or
something's on there too little gojita
little spice
paprika hate it yeah i don't hate it i
like that um but i don't like to i don't
like crumbs on my butter i gotta i keep
a clean butter yeah i don't like it
getting melted and then looking melted
you know what i mean it was
yeah
yeah it's no good it's like caulk or
something you ever put butter in the
microwave how quick it melts you got
about three seconds yeah it goes quick
it's a fantastic product i want the
microwave or the butter um this one's
just crazy this is from jimmy two times
never had a question right ever
cauterize a cut with a bic lighter
that sounds like real like yeah what do
you rambo
that seems like it would make it worse
yeah i don't think that's a very there's
a very small parameter of cuts
where it's like the lighter's not going
to do anything or the lighter is going
to make it worse if you if you heated up
a piece of metal and then rolled it over
that i could see that
i don't know but with a lighter we got
this we've gotten this question a lot to
be honest really yeah a lot
which i don't god it's got to be job
site [ __ ] but i mean also at the same
time like i guess if you're like out in
the woods or you're not i don't know
that seems more [ __ ] hillbilly to me
i mean if you're in new york city and
you're cauterizing yourself with a bic
lighter when there's a hospital or an
urgent care [ __ ] at least
no more than two blocks away at any time
you're just drunk yeah you're just out
for a good time partying
yeah that's bananas um
this one we were kind of just talking
about first time long time brian blue
balls uh have you ever gotten food at an
airport you landed at
no but i want to all of the time all of
the time you do
i want to get out of the airport get
into the city see what's going on yeah
but we never do that that's what i'm
saying we're always so hard up for time
we usually go to lunch
yeah but i mean it's not like just
first of all we're not in the city to
see what's going on just eat at the
airport i don't want to but if i'm
hungry they don't they don't serve you
on the [ __ ] flights anymore the
[ __ ] biscoff cookies ain't cutting it
i wanted to ask you about that what uh
when we flew to france we were served a
nice meal
every time i fled a hawaii nice meal
that trip at the
cali was six hours man that flight
seemed like where the [ __ ] was the meal
they stopped doing it domestic
really
that's wild
dude you fly [ __ ] you fly to europe
they they serve yeah they're coming
around every 45 minutes here's the
drinks here's a coffee here's your meal
here's a snack here's a drink again they
were coming in with cups of water on
that flight not even [ __ ] bottles i
don't mind a cup of water they always
hit you at the right time
they got a pretty timed out i gotta give
them that that trash can lid full of
cups you're dying for anything we're
gonna hit turbulence put a lid on this
goddamn thing but i'll take it
hey they do get you good pretzels
cookies and [ __ ] shitty coffee yikes
that's trashy
what that i don't like that not that i
the meals aren't great but yeah you know
it's dinner time everyone's eating them
you got the movie going distraction for
me it's like hey let me focus on this
[ __ ] pasta primavera for 10 minutes
so i'm not thinking about my ex's
nothing about my [ __ ] demise at 33
000 feet
i'm not worried about hearing an engine
go or something you know what i mean
start remembering you're in a toothpaste
40 000 feet above the air
35 000 feet above your head son of a
[ __ ] uh but they were staying they're
hard up for pilots these days they're
very understand a lot of pilot fatigue
really yeah a lot of pilots they want to
hire like
20 000 new pilots like in the next
couple of months
maybe you can get your wings
think i could yeah i would never do that
i see it
because i see the i see the instagram
videos i'm landing the plane and it's
not just like
it's
they're doing like this [ __ ] and that
they're landing a plane get the [ __ ] out
of here now don't we have computers for
that [ __ ]
it should be able to land itself
okay just saying they're looking after
the guys going back and forth and all
that crap
scary plus the windows too small that is
so weird to me why can't we get a
[ __ ] bigger window on this [ __ ]
goddamn thing why why you looking it's
like a snowstorm and you only scraped
off the a little hole so you could see
out of
they get out of the plane quick too
they're never up there i always want to
say hey man thanks they're
long gone they want to talk to a big fat
mouth breather
hey jim that fat ass in 38 38c say good
job
no i know you mean they skedaddle right
quick sometimes they'll hang around or
like the b squad hangs around sometimes
there's a guy there you know
i want the captain
who was on the stick
not looking to talk to the radar guy
the [ __ ] the guy with a guy controlling
a radio hey buddy [ __ ] put on drake
playlist and keep it moving will you i
handle the ac get out of my face
finally cowboy will ya
who dropped us in from 20 000 feet over
st louis that's what i'm looking for
all right let's do one or two more then
we got a skidaddy uh mike g first time
long time ever been to a wedding where
instead of a flower girl a friend tosses
out the airplane bottles of liquor to
the crowd before the bride walks out
that is
next level trash i thought you were
going to say the dog comes down the
aisle
that's a tough look too but i kind of
if they play ball if the flower girl or
the or the ring bearer plays ball and
they're good it's okay but sometimes you
get these bozo kids
they're crying they're wandering around
they're spilling the flowers yeah
putting on a show here let's go oh wait
for this where are we doing the wedding
we got the whole infield of the daytona
500. oh that'd be a good time it would
be good why the race is going on
do you ever get the headphones on
looks like you're laying on a plane
that's pretty tricky
there goes junior into the corner
uh that's pretty trashy what airplane
bottle is a liquor at a wedding what do
you think yeah that's tough it's like
the thing with trash is like we're all
trash obviously but you gotta try a
little like you don't need that
that's just like we're being trashy just
to be trashy
you know what i mean can i ask you this
buddy i'm right here as a friend sure
um
if you guys ever decided that you would
have kids
would you do
one of those bozo
gender reveals no
not not no you don't have to film it
well then why am i doing it if toby if
t-bone's not there i'm not [ __ ] not
wasting the man hours
this is content you would never do one
of those no i think i would want to know
just [ __ ] tell me have the [ __ ]
you know those things are the guy with
the magnifying glass they've let the
forest fires people getting hurt oh yeah
this that nobody wants to be there
because when you look at other other
people in the video they're like yeah
all right the guy hits the wrong one
does this does that that shit's real
trash it's also like nobody gives a [ __ ]
unless it's like the mom the aunt
whatever like clothes but like
the [ __ ] brother-in-law don't care
uh that's a bad look don't do that if
you're out there stop [ __ ] doing that
or if you do it do a small circle with
your loved ones don't film it and put it
on [ __ ] instagram
um also what do i know
not much not much
um all right let's do two more then
we'll skid out pete robinson first time
a long time when at the beach as a kid
do you ever dig a hole to china [ __ ]
yeah
never got there but i tried oh yeah yeah
plus i was the i was too scared of the
water once you hit the water no i was
too scared of the water to go in there
by myself
as a little kid you know to go in the
water by yourself so my dad had to dig
me a [ __ ] little whole kid yeah
i was in the hole
whoa yes fragile freddie merman
in the woods sitting in the dirt yeah
sitting in a [ __ ] [ __ ] peeing
myself sitting in a hot [ __ ] puddle
oh yeah i was a big puddle kid
you don't say i played in a lot of
puddles right i like a good puddle like
a good like baseball field puddle
not bad yeah
i uh
we
yeah of course you know you would try
that you would think you know i don't
know if i i was ever really on target to
hit it i don't know you know where i
would have ended up if i got deep enough
uh just it would just fill up with water
because it would beat the waters
underneath there
yeah magellan i know i didn't know
i don't know how deep you went what
that's why you can't build on sand this
is water
sure
we're learning and you're
really pulling out all the stops today
um
i don't know if i ever said this but my
one i think i might have my one cousin i
was at the beach with them and they
would wait for everybody to leave
and take their holes
so like if we were sitting here right me
and you were together uh-huh
and you know
t-bones over there digging a hole
digging a big hole him and his dad or
whatever when team at five o'clock six
o'clock whenever the beach starts
letting off
t-bone and his dad leave
me and you pick up our chairs our
blankets our towels our toys and go over
there and steal this hole
you starting digging more just playing
in the whole way in a whole but like
relocate the whole family and then like
when a bigger one opens up 20 feet away
you go after that you're sending out
scouts i felt like a poacher dude it
didn't feel right we got a four footer
down by the top we didn't [ __ ] earn
this first of all all right
it was real weird that was a fun time
though that's a fun time and also uh it
was big in the foley house in the winter
after the snow plow came through and
made a little mountain oh you think i
did glow in there oh man that was a lot
of gi joe special operations going on in
that [ __ ] mountain yeah
touching your wee wee
yeah good stuff but we gotta wrap it up
here gang listen we
love you to death thank you for
everything come out and see a live show
we're having a good time out there and
we will see you next week
peace